y conoce segundo evitaba el digamos a
hablar de lo ocurrido en japón el día
viernes pasado tras el asesinato del ex
primer ministro shinzo abe un hecho casi
impensable en un país con una estricta
regulación de las armas en las mínimas
tasas de violencia e inseguridad tanto
que es habitual que los políticos hagan
por ejemplo sus mitin de campaña en
plena calle con poca seguridad como lo
hacía en el momento de ser asesinado
saludo entonces a nuestro segundo
invitado al día ls fernando pedrosa
profesor de la carrera de ciencia
política de la facultad de ciencias
sociales de la uba gracias al profesor
por estar con nosotros en directo
américa de france 24
analicemos entonces fernando el contexto
como ocurrió el viernes este asesinato a
plena luz del día del ex primer ministro
sin suave y le preguntó si esto o un
caso similar digamos había pasado
anteriormente en japón
hola muy buen día bueno efectivamente es
una sociedad que tiene fama de ser muy
segura y con muchas restricciones en el
uso de las armas pero también tiene una
historia de violencia sobre todo previo
en la guerra mundial
1990 por ahí se mataron asesinaron a
varios ministros pedidos ministros y es
una sociedad con la tradición en general
violenta no ven en la violencia del
crimen o en el crimen como conocemos
desde robos a mano armada o asesinatos
en la vía pública pero así como la
tradición es muy dura que se vio sobre
todo cuando japón en la segunda guerra
mundial invadió china y los países
asiáticos hay una tradición de violencia
existente y todas las medidas que se
tomaron para aplacarlas también son una
muestra de que esto existía sin embargo
en las estadísticas y en la vida
cotidiana eso no se ve
claro le quería preguntar también
profesor fernando como esto digamos va a
impactar o como esto ha tenido
repercusiones hasta el momento en la
sociedad en la sociedad japonesa no
digamos que el asesinato e inusual a un
ex primer ministro en plena campaña para
unas elecciones legislativas
bueno efectivamente esto fue de un
impacto inmenso pensemos que a ver a un
ex ministro del lugar además el que más
duro en el cargo un líder internacional
una persona muy respetada muy conocida e
incluso también en la discrepancia pero
efectivamente esto no se sabe muy bien
qué consecuencias tendrá el medio plazo
pero efectivamente lo que sabemos es que
el impacto fue altísimo y la primer
muestra de esto lo que puedo decir es
que en las elecciones de el día de ayer
día domingo el partido que pertenecía
del partido del ministro
bueno tuvo un triunfo contundente en las
elecciones lo cual también tiene que ver
con la repercusión y con el impacto de
la muerte de a menos claro además
digamos el primer ministro actual fukuda
dijo que pues iba a seguir de alguna
manera el legado del yin suave en sobre
todo cambiar esta constitución pacifista
de japón postguerra realmente este
cambio de constitución que era también
una de las banderas principales el ex
primer ministro ave se pudiera se
pudiera dar en un corto plazo o fernando
bueno es difícil pensarlo no pero en
contexto está viviendo el mundo el
contexto está viviendo la región y sobre
todo japón que también tiene un litigio
pendiente con rusia por unas islas
yo diría que la constitución japonesa
fue redactada después de sea una guerra
mundial o sea estamos hablando hace
mucho tiempo con otra solución mundial y
esa esa constitución le pone muchas
trabas al armado de las fuerzas armadas
y sobre todo a la participación de japón
en conflictos externos que está
prohibido tajantemente entonces
evidentemente japón tiene que modernizar
de hecho lo de hecho lo ha venido
haciendo informalmente y con algunas
enmiendas pero efectivamente necesita un
referéndum constitucional para cambiar
la constitución
hoy está más cerca que ayer los
resultados de hoy son están más cerca
que ayer quizás la muerte de ave sea
como dicen los españoles un revulsivo
que permita este cambio y finalmente de
alguna manera su legado tenga tenga
vigencia y yo creo que eso se va a ver
en los próximos meses no creo que sea
algo de cortísimo plazo claro volviendo
al caso de abril lo que el hecho
lamentable digamos con este asesinato
que vimos el día viernes pues también
como como lo decían en introducción
estos políticos hacen sus mítines de
campaña digamos a plena calle con poca
con poca seguridad como por por esa
seguridad incluso que pues que brinda en
la sociedad japonesa o las autoridades
japonesas esto cambiaría lo que ocurrió
el viernes de alguna forma la forma de
hacer campaña o mítines políticos de los
japoneses como para prevenir una guerra
futuro
yo creo que no la forma de hacer
política de hacer actos son también
formas que tienen que ver con la
tradición con la cultura de los países
lo que sí podrá cambiar me parece es el
nivel de seguridad de las altas los
altos funcionarios del gobierno de los
políticos ahí va separado también en
caso de en suecia eso se pasó también la
muerte de de primeros ministros de
ministros en la calle en formarse
sin seguridad sin ningún tipo de medida
y bueno eso luego con el tiempo hizo
cambiar la situación yo creo que en
japón lo que va a cambiar es darle mayor
seguridad los funcionarios sobre todo a
los que tiene responsabilidades
gubernamentales o ex ministros pero no
creo que cambie de ninguna manera
expresión política claro o fernando y
tampoco digamos que cambiaría la
política armamentista armamentista de
japón digamos en cuanto a la sociedad
civil estos rigurosos obviamente
procesos para poder adquirir un arma en
en japonés son extremadamente digamos
difíciles poder tener la pasan por
obviamente estudios y pues una cantidad
de trabas por decir decirlo para que no
cualquiera tenga esta arma diga lo que
pasó fue un hecho aislado además porque
fue con un arma que construyó esta
persona en su misma casa y no
precisamente por adquirir un arma
digamos en una venta de armas si
efectivamente las leyes son muy
rigurosas son rigurosas y además son
permanentes cada poco tiempo hay que
renovarlas como ejemplo de tiro que
cuando se compran balas en japón hay que
llevar el casquillo de las que se usaron
para no para que no puedas acumular
proyectiles pero obviamente hoy el arma
casera se puede también hacer en la casa
como este asesino que tenía un montón de
armas casillas a su casa entonces creo
que la legislación mostró que funcionaba
justo que no se pueden tener armas no
tiene o que se toque ese tema me parece
que eso va a seguir igual ya para
finalizar como ve con estas elecciones
aprovechando que fueron en el día de
ayer pues de todo lo que tiene que ver
con este nuevo nuevo parlamento y la
política japonesa de aquí a un corto
plazo
bueno lo que se votó ayer es en la
cámara sabemos de la cámara menos
importante la cámara de senadores la
cámara alta no en un sistema como el
japonés eres lo que sea una cámara de
representantes o diputados la más
importante pero sin embargo fue a
elección
digamos trascendente fue la elección
donde se llevó el 50% de las bancas en
juego el partido oficialista donde quedó
reforzado el primer ministro y yo creo
que quedó con la posibilidad haciendo
alianzas parlamentarias de conseguir el
verdadero objetivo que se planteó que
planteó va a haber que ir a la reforma
constitucional y posicionar japón en el
mundo que viene en un mundo que se
sostiene que va a ser más difícil más
violento y más complejo